everyone thinks coming out is easy these
days
but it's not they're in this perfect
little uh
summer bubble as victor says and um he's
you know like really comfortable with
benji now like
they've definitely kind of like gotten
used to each other they're
really really into each other and now
it's just like about
time to like kind of opening up victor
to open up himself to
the rest of the school and like you know
establishing and sticking up for who he
is as a person
hey so we should probably talk about
what we're going to tell everyone
i want to tell people no one said coming
out was going to be easy and while
victor might have some new challenges
this school year
there's no challenge when it comes to
the chemistry between victor
and benji i'm terrified to have sex for
the first time
if you're with the right person it
doesn't matter
i think having um playing opposite
michael's
has always felt really um kind of
electric like there's just always been
this energy there like
from the very first chemistry read that
him and i did to
every time him and i do a scene we we
both
really commit to it and we're both
really like
we're just both trying to honor these
characters i know that i know a lot of
actors like to say things like that but
that's the truth
i think it's really fun to work with
another actor that's just so willing to
you know explore and and really try new
things and like really push each other
like he really pushes me to be
better i think that that's honestly the
best thing you could ask for you know